hey everyone this is Stephen Weintraub
with collider and I am here at our
studio at the cinema center at marble
and uh I think I said marble wrong did
you say at Marvel is this already
becoming about Deadpool it is not
becoming about Deadpool I promise you I
don't want to get in trouble
I have so many responses to that but
anyway I'm just gonna say we are here
for all the light we cannot see I see
Netflix being like you are not here
promoting something else yeah but we're
definitely using this stuff do not cut
it out right
um I really want to start with a sincere
and I really mean this congratulations
on this project
um I thought you did such a great job
with this
um and I'm sure you're feeling relieved
that he didn't f it up you know I'm just
being completely honest thrilled Shawn
did an incredible job but how nervous
were you initially are you can I just
take over that absolutely when you heard
because I know they had tried to develop
it as a movie and then you heard that
the guy was who had I had done some
neither Museum movies and we had
produced a rival and stranger things
how'd you feel at first you're like how
and what were world does that make sense
or at first I was thrilled I was so
excited because the original plan when
we sold the film Rights was for like a
hundred minute feature so to be able to
expand the material and our first phone
call that Sean was really emphasizing
this can be four hours the novel's 500
pages so to be able to turn it into
something for even we were talking about
six maybe something with a lot more
space to explore the characters and the
settings you know I was thrilled so I
was really excited however yeah when
they did send me the link to watch the
episodes I think my password is like
very very nervous seven or something
like that so I was a little nervous I
did not know that but I was thrilled I
will say that um and I say this With all
sincerity if this had been a two-hour
movie it would have sucked like straight
up like this there's too much material
in this and the advantage of streaming
and Netflix to be able to do this is it
gave the project enough money and time
to be able to tell this story but Sean I
definitely have a specific question for
you this is so out of your wheelhouse
so not anything that you've done before
talk a little bit about was there
hesitation to take on a project that was
so different or was there just tons of
excitement to show that you could do
something like this yeah well I feel
like I mean you and I have known each
other since Real Steel I think and uh
and so you know all my movies and shows
whether they're action or comedy I'm
always trying to co-opt a small part of
its DNA for heart and for emotion and uh
and but you have to be judicious and how
you do that in a movie like free guy or
Adam project but always coming up as a
film student as an a younger director I
wanted to make all kinds of stuff and so
for me like my Idols are people like
Peter Weir people like Spielberg people
who are not limited to genre and who get
the privilege of working in a bunch of
them and so uh I read this book when it
first came out I wanted it so badly the
rights were gone they were developing it
as a movie and and I felt like oh I feel
like I know how to do this and and I
will say
maybe I was apprehensive on one level
but I just had this gut feeling that I
knew these characters I connected with
these themes and the truth is that being
able to tell a story where you don't
have to service the joke you don't have
to service the action set piece you're
just servicing character and writing and
you're bringing that world to life that
was liberating and really really
gratifying to me I would say it was
Sean's wheelhouse young actors lots of
heart lots of humanity of course maybe
the sets the 1938 cars and stuff were
new for him but I what was so
encouraging to me when he first
contacted me about the project was this
is somebody who knows how to tell a
story about curious kids with a lot of
heart who want the best for each other
but circumstances are making things
difficult that is I've never linked this
to my body of work in that way and so
now thank you I'm a little troublingly
self-aware now uh but thanks for making
that connection uh so this is you you
essentially made a four-hour movie
that's in four parts
um and I know that because I spoke to
you we were talking when you were
shooting at what point of the shoot were
you like what the f have I signed on for
well it was I mean we filmed in Budapest
it was a long shoot it was 80 something
days I'm dealing with hundreds of extras
and Military sequences and War scenes
and covid oh yes well and covid and
being on the other side of the world and
eight hours ahead of my family my
company 21 laps and all my friends
um so it on the one hand it felt
daunting but I will say that every day I
had some sense of oh this is going to be
worth it this is going to be worth it
and when I first put the show together
there have been many moments in the edit
room on the mixed stage at the scoring
stage with James Newton Howard where
I've sat back and I've said very kind of
consciously to myself oh this was worth
it this is why I went through all that
because I got to make something lyrical
and epic and hopefully audiences will
agree moving in a way that was new to me
but which I'd always aspire to I
definitely want to talk about your lead
um and I I really also want to give
credit to Netflix for letting you cast a
complete unknown but talk a little bit
about the casting process and because
she's so good and I don't want to
pronounce her name wrong which is why
Arya Mia Liberty um and and uh in fact
we have two girls who play Marie the
lead the lead character in Tony's book
is uh Marie lore who's a blind French
girl and I needed an eight-year-old and
I needed a 20 year old and we did an
open casting call and thanks to Netflix
which is this globally ubiquitous
company we put out we just put out kind
of like a flyer online anyone could send
in an audition cited actors unsighted
actors low vision non-actors and I got
this audition from a non-actor and her
name was Arya and she is a Fulbright
scholar PhD student in rhetoric this is
not only a first part it was her first
audition
and when I saw this audition I knew
there might be something special there
and with every Zoom with every callback
that gut feeling was confirmed and
you've seen the show it was it's a
really masterful performance but again
this was someone who came to acting
having never done it so imagine any of
us here learning how to do our job while
doing that job in front of 300 people it
came to acting being told she wasn't
able to act as a young girl too so she
really was discouraged she was told she
has memories of being a kid and being
told by theater teachers and others
that's not for you that's not going to
be your path and so it's just kind of
miraculous like a thousand I think Sean
said numbing quantity of auditions she
left that she put on her grandmother's
clothes so she was wearing period
clothing and she just screamed Marie I
should also add Steve it's not just that
she came to this saying I don't know
know how to do this but I want to be
great tell me how to be great I'm going
to work to be great so tell me how to do
that and I did and she could handle in
fact she wanted Candor which not all
actors do right she wanted to know how
to be great at this new Endeavor but she
also every day helped me because the
script might say oh Marie you know feels
for the couch and sits down but Arya
would say well how long have I lived in
this room because if I've lived here for
a year and I live alone and no one moves
Furniture I don't need to feel for that
couch I know where it's going to be
because I've mapped the space that I'm
intimate with so things like that right
that are are flouting the tropes and
cliches of how we see this disability
represented a hundred years of movies
where a blind person has not played the
blind character and so when you get two
blind girls playing this blind character
I become as much the student as the a
leader what shines through in her
performance is not her disability but
her capabilities and she's such a
capable character so I I was really
moved by her performance oh no 100 and
by the way if her performance doesn't
work the whole thing falls apart yeah I
mean this thing does not work so one of
the things is that and and I'm curious
for for both of you so obviously when we
see Nazis depicted in movies and
basically they're always evil because
they're evil you know but you
have a a
I guess it right is you do have a
sympathetic character that is a Nazi and
and it made me realize that maybe in a
way that you know not everyone was
gung-ho and they were still pulled in
well that was probably some of what you
were scratching at when you wrote this
character right absolutely I mean we
live at this time of polarity where
you're just supposed to make a snap
judgment about everybody but history
life is so much more complex than that
Hitler Youth is sweeping kids when
they're 10 11 12 years old at the end of
the war they're sending 14 year olds off
to battle so of course he's being
indoctrinated by a new technology uh
radio that's coming to the world and is
able to spread disinformation in a way
that humans were not able to do that at
a time so I hope even as you recognize
he's making morally wrong decisions you
understand how Werner got to that
situation in his life look being honest
and so we should say that you should
give a little bit more background on the
character for people haven't seen or
read the book um or or seen the trailer
but um uh well let's start with that
maybe you should I I mean I'll I'll take
a whack at that it um so one of the two
leads is a character named Werner who is
a German orphan who shows this early
almost Prodigy level skill with radios
and he is taken from his orphanage and
put into one of these Nazi training
schools that were historically very real
and and would often indoctrinate the
Youth of Germany into this into this
military but into this ideology verner's
a character who is not indoctrinated
into that ideology who has a love for
technology has a talent for this
emerging technology but who is actually
committed to keeping his soul clean who
has a sister who literally says to him
when he's taken away do not let them
convince you do not let them change you
keep the frequency in your head had the
same you mean 1310 go on yes I do mean
frequency 13. it's an inside joke inside
joke you really should see it eventually
you're gonna see it and then you'll
understand that but anyway that to
Tony's point that was the point is that
certainly the Nazis are some of the most
cruel evil people we've seen in human
history but that doesn't tell the full
story of every individual and Werner is
a fictional individual but one who
reminds us that the Nuance of what a
person is is not fully described by the
uniform they're put in also we should
point out there are some very evil Nazis
in the movie so you know oh yeah this is
hardly a a an apologist uh work you know
I am you know as a Canadian Jew back
here in Canada
um there was a choice obviously the book
is not a holocaust story but is a World
War II story and the reality of what the
Germans did in that time is abhorrent
and appalling and the fact that we're
even
talking about or hearing about a
Resurgence of that ideology is
grotesque so um so definitely our show
is committed to showing the grotesquery
of that mindset
um but it's also really kind of zooming
in on this one character and and this
one girl and this one boy and how their
Destinies intersect talk a little bit
about uh the fact that you were filming
very close to uh the Ukraine border uh
and that war was going on and you know
what it meant filming so close get this
so we're in the neighboring country to
Ukraine we're filming scenes of The
Exodus of refugees out of Paris when the
Germans invaded some of the extras
playing
refugees marching West
were Ukrainian refugees who had marched
West into Hungary where we were filming
so that was a mirroring of real life
that was heartbreaking
um and kind of just took our Breath Away
on those days I'm curious and you know
this is a question I've asked you a
thousand times and I will ask it again
um you know that and and the editing
process is ultimately where this whole
thing comes together so what did you
learn from friends and family screenings
or test screenings that impacted the the
final four episodes in ways you didn't
expect really good question
um let's see I learned that it's hard to
feel for a character
I'd read the book right and I'd read the
scripts so we would have certain scenes
particularly with Hugh Laurie's
character atien
um
who is a damaged character he's
traumatized from the first world war and
he lives agoraphobically in his house
initially there was a Structure to one
of the episodes where we were asking the
audience to feel for that character
before they had connected with that
character so we did a fairly radical
restructure on episode four in
particular in order to vest the audience
with Hugh Laurie's character
before we're asking the audience to feel
for him and so that was a big Revelation
that was I've never done this where I
watched the first cut that was assembled
per the script and I felt instantly why
am I not feeling it why am I not feeling
it and so I sat there and I hand row
every scene of the show on an index card
and I put them out on the floor and then
I started moving things around and then
I said to my editor okay do this version
Let me see this version and so we
literally restructured episode four
in an attempt to fully engage the
audience and and and to have them feel
the stakes of the characters before you
see any outcomes of characters yeah um
it's so editing is so amazing like
people don't even realize man I mean
performances are constructed in the edit
room performances are and can be
destroyed in the edit room I will say
this about actors though I love actors I
think that's clear from the way I cast
all my movies and so if an actor's
giving me the good I'll let that
take run long because those are the
moments where they're not talking or
it's not a scripted Behavior where it
feels like oh man there's something
really authentic happening here and I
just want to live with it and when it's
done well
um and when you allow the audience to
kind of have those moments where it's a
little Messier a little more surprising
uh those are my favorite ones I am
curious when you finally so you get the
link or however you're going to watch it
right what is it like first of all did
you actually actually have any notes or
anything that you saw and you were like
we really should do this uh well of
course you know you're seeing scripts
all along so I have plenty of notes as
we're getting there uh I know that it
was a final cut when I got to see it but
there was one Chiron you know what those
are this little date thing at the bottom
that was wrong I'm like I think I can
tell Sean about this yeah but you're
making it sound I mean the truth is that
in script especially and that's when I
was most nervous
um because we it's an adaptation right
there's things that are in the book that
aren't in the show there's things that
Stephen Knight invented that are not in
the book
um I I didn't tell the full ending from
um so there were changes and and Tony I
have to say he had a fair number of
notes in script form many of which Steve
and I applied in the rewrites
um but he also came to this
understanding that this is a different
medium and it's never going to be 100
faithful it's so uh liberating to be
reminded that if I want to blow up a
building it's free I just use language
right these really inexpensive materials
everything that Sean decides costs money
so you know he has to make an infinity
of decisions that as a novelist I'm just
totally free to make but I was also
quite jealous of the collaborative
nature of his job every decision has to
be made by me when he's talking about
ways that Arya brought new things to the
character that weren't in the script or
that we couldn't foresee as sighted
people that's that's the kind of gift of
collaborative work so I was really moved
to see him work like a general with this
vast Army of people keep everybody quiet
everybody's in Mass there's like this
epic Heat Wave like roasting Europe and
he's got everybody positive late into
the afternoon on the set I just was so
moved by his leadership skills on the
whole set in Budapest well I always say
like because I've spoken to a lot of
authors and about adaptations and the
truth is the book is always there it's
not like the book has gone away it's
just this is the version that you know
what I mean yeah this is a different
thing this is a totally different medium
and best path to success is to let Sean
make the thing he wants to make whether
or not it's faithful to in every single
detail to the book doesn't matter nearly
as much as in terms of the heart the
Beating Heart of it do you care about
these people and do you feel for these
kids when the circumstances of History
are compressing them into these boxes
that they really don't want to be in I'm
curious with uh because obviously with
Netflix uh you want to end things on
Cliffhangers so because obviously it
makes people want to click play on the
next episode I for example episode one
ends on a cliffhanger episode two has
stuff like so how did was that in the
script phase was that
um was is that like a note that Netflix
gives or you sort of know because you've
worked with them you're talking to the
producer of stranger things right so
like the duffers one of their North Star
principles is stick The Landing always
stick to Landing but have people leaning
in for what is coming next and so I I
added to Stephen Knight all four
episodes all three rather episodes were
built with a cliffhanger ending but the
way that my editor and I edited those
final 60 seconds of every episode for
one thing I know that has to be that has
to be maximum captivating and and and I
mean there's a bunch of things that I
see or stranger things inspired in this
show even though they seem like they
have nothing in common but some of the
metrics to the editing some of the
heightened sound work that we do on
stranger things we absolutely do in this
but definitely the way that we try to
stick the landing but invite that play
next play next
um I guess after eight years of stranger
things that's baked into my sensibility
and I wanted it for this too my son got
to visit the set and he was his first
year of college so we got to see the
show I think maybe in mid-april when he
got home from college I'm like oh and
you're gonna get to see the show that we
helped make that we were there for and
he could not stop himself fasten up
between one and two and two and three
and three and four I'm like don't you
want to eat or go to the bathroom or
something but he was just like here we
go I need the next one oh no I'm letting
everyone know episode and episode one
ends on a cliffhanger and episode I mean
you're gonna keep pushing play one two
and three are all Cliffhangers there's
no secret there and um I'm showing my
hand but again it's like sometimes you
can know the magic trick but if it works
you still love the magic trick listen
it's a four-part series like we anyway
um so I am curious uh you've obviously
have a long relationship with Netflix
and uh it's commend like the book was
super popular but talk a little bit
about was it tough to get them to say we
want to make this and was it tough you
know what I mean like or do they sort of
because of your success with them
they're sort of like we're in the Sean
business
certainly they say yes more readily
because they're in the Sean business and
I've tried to earn that Faith by
rewarding them on the bets they make on
me and you know whether it's been Shadow
and bone or stranger things things or
Unsolved Mysteries or all light we
cannot see your atom project we we've
had a good run we're having a good run
um but I would just say that uh you know
Ted and and Bella bajaria they were
really blunt they're like look we're
backing you you want to do this with
unknown low vision or blind girls
playing lead okay
um we're gonna give you enough money to
do it right I will tell you that the
budget was not nearly a Stratosphere
because a lot of the budgets we hear on
other limiteds both in Netflix and at
other networks and platforms uh I pride
myself on being efficient and pragmatic
as a producer but yeah I guess they're
willing to bet on me this was such a big
title that it becomes its own form of Ip
but they acquired the book we got
Stephen Knight who is as good a
screenwriters you can get but then the
big bet was oh wait you're gonna cast
people that no one's ever heard of to
play the two leads the boy and the girl
um to which I said yes thank you but I
don't want to give any money back but
I'll tell you what I'm gonna go find
some famous people to play these two
adult males sure and um thankfully I
delivered with Ruffalo and Hugh Laurie
I'm just about a time with you and I'm
going to apologize to you right now but
um we have a long-standing interview
history you might say where towards the
end I might ask him about some other
projects and so I just wanted to so I'm
gonna quickly quick updates
um I'm assuming nothing has happened
with Star Wars
we were just starting the process of
developing my movie and a writer strike
happened so we are we are in that
holding pattern that so much of our
industry is in Real Steel TV series
same I could literally say see above C
above sure um same still I guess I've
told you I want it as badly as the
lovers of Real Steel want it so alive
paused do you think a free guy sequel
actually happens or is it sort of like
this was so good and came out so great
do we want to make another I think it is
definitely not uh assured we love free
guy and the love for free guy that has
kind of resonated in like after shocks
if you will in the last couple years
that's been thrilling to Ryan and I we
are developing a sequel
um but the truth is it you now have
Barbie that has obviously left to Mark
about a character in a fictional world
who comes to self-awareness so we're
only going to make free guy too if it's
different than the first movie and if
it's different from other movies I'm a
fan of Shadow and Bone
I don't know what's the status of season
three neither do I yet okay I'll leave
it there yeah so you were filming how
many days had you actually been filming
before you got shut down on Deadpool 35
days oh so you were really into no we're
in it like we we were exactly halfway
through filming Deadpool and then we
stopped can I ask you was there any
consideration in the filming in your
first 35 days knowing that the strike
might happen where you wanted to shoot
scenes that had VFX so you could get
those done do you know what I mean yeah
of course I do that would have been
smarter than I am that would have been
so Savvy but I guess maybe like others
in our industry I somehow thought this
strike this second strike would be
averted uh and then suddenly it was upon
us and I had to send several hundred
people home and uh and they're still
waiting to come back to work so I'm just
really I'm I don't use this word lightly
but I am yearning for a resolution that
feels fair and Equitable and gets this
industry back to work I know I have to
rap with you but I'm gonna do one
follow-up on Deadpool uh because people
don't know much about it can you tease
anything about the the movie in terms of
what it's about I'll just say that it
very much leans into the fact that this
one is
Deadpool and Wolverine this one is much
more of a two-hander than either
Deadpool movie has been it's still as
I've told you raw audacious R-rated very
much so but you have two major movie
stars together in a movie playing their
most iconic signature roles that is
director heaven and so the story the
tone the movie itself leans into that
gift of having Deadpool Wolverine
co-starring in a movie for the first
time so uh we're definitely not running
away from that uh my last question for
you um I know that you always direct
episodes of stranger things when the
strike ends they're obviously going to
start filming stranger things and you're
going to be working on Deadpool do you
think you're actually going to direct
any of the final season like for sure I
bleed for that show
I've been alongside Matt and Ross
stuffer for all these years I direct
episodes every year it's a part of our
Brotherhood it's a part of my commitment
and my love of the show connecting with
it as a director as well as a executive
producer so I will go through hoops to
figure out calendars to direct at least
one episode I was going to say it's
normally episode three or four but I
don't know if it'll be that's the part
that's up in the air I really mean a
sincere congratulations on all the light
it is so well done I know audiences are
going to love it congratulations on
everything and
um and Sean knows I wouldn't actually
say that if that's very true he can be a
mean little bastard that's not that's
actually not no that's not true but his
enthusiasm is never fake no I I don't
fake it like I really have to like it to
say something like that on camera thank
you thank you anymore is it always Steve
it doesn't matter for those of us who've
known you for a while it's a whole thing
everyone is watching tune into all the
light it's gonna be on Netflix in early
November November 2nd and I really
appreciate you guys coming in and I wish
you nothing but the best thank you